HR how are you tomorrow DP page on there
but I'm good how do you sum up what
happened last night well you knew that
Verlander was gonna have to go deep
because the kind of the long the
distance in the bullpen for the when he
Astros is going to be tough to get
through to get to the closer and even
close it out but I thought also the big
key was going to be more in Los Angeles
side and it came down to really a couple
decisions but the one in the fifth
inning with Hill I thought he did a
great job of pitching to Redick to get
the strikeout knowing the pitcher
Verlander is on deck they're not going
to pinch-hit for Verlander he got out of
that and then the big move was was Dave
Roberts going to the bullpen right there
yeah I didn't think that he was going to
go that fast to go get the guy brought
in at the time and so that was the big
thing for me well I look at tonight and
I don't know how this plays out for both
of these teams but certainly the Dodgers
who have relied on that bullpen it's the
best bullpen in baseball but going into
tonight is there anybody who's got a
decided advantage when it comes to
pitching well I think the Dodgers do and
you know Kenley Jansen is a guy that
they've used through the years in more
than one inning you know he's gone
multiple innings before I know he did it
last year in the postseason
believe it or not yeah sure so ready to
go you look on the other side they're
gonna start my colors and the colors you
know I don't know what six innings last
time but starters are not going deep and
that has been the challenge and the
Astros have been digging inside to find
out did they go back to Giles and
struggle to maybe close it out for them
and you know I think the answer is right
in front of us really because most men
both these managers have said we trust
our team I trust my guys and Dave
Roberts going to go to his bullpen and
at the end of the day you're gonna see
the same thing from AJ Hinch you know
kershel is a question mark
in coming in and relief because it it
just feels like there's a there's always
a little more attack
to it with Kershaw I know he pitched
brilliantly to start the World Series
got roughed up the last start but now
you bring him in out of his routine in
from the bullpen how does that change
does that matter to you at all as you're
watching this unfold well I think he
needs it you know I I know he doesn't
want to end the season the way he did
and if it means for him to match up for
one or two hitters or maybe one or two
innings I think he sees him to get the
ball he wants to baseball it has not
been pretty I mean he had a four nothing
lead he had a seven four lead he wasn't
able to hold them I don't think you know
you want to see that in for him like
that so I think he's in the game
regardless the key guy tonight is gonna
be you Darvish you know I mean darvis
did not pitch well the other day but
only 249 pitches so we're gonna see a
stronger better darvis and because of
the things I'm saying right now I really
do lean towards the Dodgers I just think
their pitching is a lot more intact your
MVP through six games is who plays a
toss-up that's a tough one
I thought it would be out to vae he's go
up some big hits when needed to but the
other day the one players has just
shined more than anybody Springer he's
just gone off I meant throw out the
first game four strikeouts for it bats
after that he has done something in
every game and I think he's probably
gonna end up being the guy who wins it
oh well if if they win it if they went
yeah if the Dodgers win it the Dodgers
are best in the season ends up being
that guy they haven't had one player
just carry him Tippie joc pederson
believe it or not I mean he's had some
of the biggest hits the ball jumps off
his bat HR it sounds different when he
hits hits the ball I don't know what it
is but I thought that when he first came
up and he was hitting bombs it's I don't
know if you've experienced that before
there's certain guys when they hit it it
just sounds different and he's one of
those guys to me that it sounds
different
I gotta give you a DP Herald funny story
okay so jock Peterson 30-30 player in
triple-a right I'm hearing about him all
offseason next ken griffey jr. so and
everybody's telling me so I covered the
Dodgers in our 30 and 30 clubs and
thirty days coverage
so I'm stand at the batting cage and Don
Mattingly as a manager at the time and
I'm like Donny man I keep hearing about
this jock Peterson all he's like all
Harold's are gonna love him kids got
power he can range left-hander I said
yeah I keep hearing he might as me
griffey where is he he goes he's right
there
I go where at he goes right there he's
in the cage hitting and I go I'm looking
for a guy with an ass I've been having
this discussion with the damage is
Justin Verlander a Hall of Famer I think
so I really do I don't see if he goes
the difference last night's at Churchill
is the Farris and look if we're talking
about Curt Schilling and his great
postseason he doesn't have the
regular-season resume of this guy you
know he's won MVPs he's won so Young's
he got ripped off on a couple of them
and with the generation today how many
guys are really gonna win 300 games or
throw the innings anymore I think he's a
Hall of Famer
yeah but Schilling is not even a Hall of
Famer well I know but everybody keeps
knocking on that door I think
Verlander's way into the Hall he doesn't
really do you don't have 200 wins
I know that he's got some he's got some
nice Awards but you know and on this
postseason record even though he's
pitched well I don't it's not something
that puts him over the top in my opinion
and Schilling had that postseason and
two remarkable runs with two different
team three different teams you want to
throw the Phillies in there as well yeah
who would you rather have Schilling or
Verlander well I think you look America
curse Julian
in the postseason I mean he's one of the
Great's of all time right yeah so okay
and he's run away with championships I
mean obviously that's what you want but
I don't know I just think that
Verlander's the class of this generation
and the story still not finished being
written I think he's with an offense
again in Houston that's going to give
him some runs he's I think he's close to
not getting in I know a lot of people
saying it's not I think he's been easy I
don't think we will see easy 300 game
winners we're not going to see 5,000
strikeouts with guys don't throw enough
there's not going to be the bodies of
work anymore
he's that last dying breed and I think
because of that he gets in I don't know
that yeah I think CC Sabathia is gonna
get in really hello Wow numbers check
out his numbers Paulie pull up McLovin
pull up Sabathia numbers here all-time
lefties with strikeouts and wins and if
you do it he's done he's like third
all-time those guys are all in
super-sized you take petted or Sabathia
if you had to have one vote well I think
we're skewed to what we saw when we were
you know in our heyday of watching
certain guys I think Andy Pettit was one
of the best pitchers that everybody
overlooked but resume I think she gets
in and Pettit to me better resume yes
boys Sabathia is ten and six in the
postseason he's he's having a nice shoe
this year 14 and 5 yeah he came back but
he was kind of left for dead before this
237 victories 146 losses 3.7 over here
er a man 250 wins and 3,000 strikeouts I
think there's only two other lefties in
the history and they're all in the Hall
of Fame is that spon and Carlton
I think so I don't even know what group
it is yeah I mean Koufax didn't have
that number of wins but man Sabathia
okay my
Mussina he's got a better resume than
Sabathia Dundee I think Mussina gets in
eventually
here's the problem I have with the Hall
of Fame I think it needs to be according
to the generation he played in because
you can't compare generations you just
can't the game changes so much and you
have to compare guys to me Don Mattingly
was one of the greatest in his
generation Steve Garvey was there just
dismissed as if they didn't play well I
can understand what that was Dale Murphy
because Murph was one of the great
hitters of his generation and I think if
if he ended up with 400 home run would
he end up with three ninety-eight and
it's like Fred McGriff like we like
round numbers and then Fred ends up with
400 home runs maybe we look at him
differently okay you tell Fred McGriff
sword L Murphy or Don Mattingly go ahead
and strike out two other time yeah well
that's why I don't know if I give credit
to these strikeout pitchers because it's
easy to get strikeouts now yeah look at
what no one Ryan was doing when these
guys were contacted you had guys who
were in the lineup just to move the
runner over like they were just trying
to get the bat on the ball these guys
are all going for the downs now so if
you're not striking out that's like sale
I mean if sale stays healthy sales gonna
strike out you know he'll probably get
up to a magic number there in his career
yeah I don't know if we solved anything
here I don't think we did okay it's good
conversation all right we saw that Joc
Peterson's not black did you can I need
another source on this can you can you
have a lighter confirmed man for me so
you have the Astros tonight I have the
Dodgers tonight right okay I just think
the pitch is deeper you got Dodgers too
huh yeah but you know how I kept saying
the Dodgers bullpen is going to be the
difference it might be the difference
now if they're gonna win it better be
the difference tonight are we watching
the greatest World Series ever I think
so I think
our time this is the best world series
that I've even last night was sort of
yeah compared to all the other ones like
two and five to eight greatest they
would stand out in just about any other
world series as the best game of those
world series and you've had two of those
games so far and you had the pitching
matchup in Game one I mean it's it's got
to come down to the final inning the
final out it just does that would be
poetic I would love that
you know it's been great for baseball a
lot of people a lot of eyeballs watching
us it's been really great for the sport
and a lot of young talent there on both
of these teams which is great oh man
you know last thing I'm throw out there
is is we were sitting there saying 20
years from now are we watching 8 maybe
10 Hall of Famers playing this series
let's see run them down you got Seager
Bellinger Correa Altuve
Kershaw Verlander anybody else in there
great I'm not in there I don't know
he'll be that that friend's guy we're
talking about he's got a sign John he
got a Hall of Fame make it another at
Cooperstown yeah I mean I'm sorry
he may get another one no no we'll see
but that's pretty alarming you look back
at it that sounds like something a topic
for MLB tonight sounds good my man thank
you been doing our show alright that's
Harold Reynolds baseball Network analyst
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]